I really had strong feelings for more
than one person and it was pretty
difficult at the end so it was it was
definitely erratic how difficult it is
I'm very happy but yeah it wasn't
without some some hard time steel a lot
of stairs more man tears and more lady
teeth more lady - how many women did you
say I love you - two - okay does that
speak to that difficult time yes okay
alright do you have any regrets at this
point um no no regrets I think that you
know things really played out
wonderfully for me wonderfully sounds
like you're engaged maybe are you in a
relationship you'll have to watch and
find out how happy are you I'm
definitely happy how do you make that
final decision it's difficult you know
you'd look for things that give you
clarity you look for a person that can
fit within your life and vice versa fit
within their lives what's a deciding
factor just compatibility you know it's
easy to get wrapped up in the
environment and to be in love going on
these amazing dates but you really have
to look past a show into your regular
life and I think that's the most
important part
[Music]